What's going on?
Lü Bu's halberd has begun to glow!
Yes, just as I figured.
That weapon…
Could it be…
-Isn't that…
-You can't be serious!
That itself is the hidden power
of us Valkyrie.
To defeat the dirty cheats
the gods use for weapons,
we have our own cheat!
Transcendence!
When a Valkyrie's body transforms
into a weapon for humans,
mankind obtains a weapon of the gods,
in other words, a sacred item.
That ability is called…
Divine Treasure Forge!
Völundr!
An unbreakable foe
and an unbreakable weapon!
That kind of world…
is the greatest!
The special abilities of the 13 Valkyrie
dwell in the weapons made through Völundr.
The fourth sister is Randgriz.
The meaning of her name is…
"Shield Breaker"!
Mjölnir is a powerful weapon of the gods
that can crush continents.
However, anyone who wields
its immense power
and intense lava-like heat
will be annihilated.
Therefore, according to Edda,
the story of Norse mythology,
Thor wears Járngreipr
to protect his hands.
In other words,
the greatest armor
in the heavens, Járngreipr,
is used to handle the greatest weapon
in the heavens, Mjölnir.
This spectacle was something
that never should have happened.